this is the technical difficulties with
playing citation needed joining me in
the studio today he reads books you know
it's Chris Joel idle last our favorite
Gavin Gavin Gavin go here and see and
the band's you spy on the internet Matt
gray hello you would cure in front of me
I have an article from Wikipedia and
these folks can't see it every fact we
get right is a point and a ding and a
special prize for particular dancers
which is today's article is the flitch
of bacon custom oh yeah good luck with
this one guys tell me that's not a
person that's how that's not a
ceremonial position now sitting in
Parliament black rod the flick showing
baby your own custom or excuse me second
Fletcher bacon the flitch of bacon is it
the custom of the flesh of baby is a
slit and a mount or cut or volume of
babies how you eat a unit of bacon
measure it's a very thick slab right
basically what you cut up to make thin
rashers of bacon right okay so we're
actually talking proper bacon I guess
size off yes
is this something like fish slapping
dance Oh with a side o bacon they can be
runnin if you care to mine with me God
la Comte an entire pit bull infant
entire pig week boy
rodents of unusual size I don't think
they exit pigs do fly anew if you stick
a jet engine on the top of them science
an experiment was carried out you have
small jet engine to actually I think
that all the steps are boundaries from
from technical mer three two and a big
morality where is the battery care I
think it's a bit way you've strata jet
engine to a period to be fair we could
use a dead pig just to touch the concept
where it heats off jet engine delicious
delicious bacon I'm thinking yeah we
wrap the outside of the pig in some fuel
that isn't as noxious as jet fuel you
know that when it inevitably crashes
both instant bacon what crackling as
well instant barbie the heat around the
edge of that all sorry
oh we just need to sneak onto the runway
at Heathrow without I assume like a
garden fork with a pig on the end we
need a military jet with an afterburner
I don't think we really need an
afterburner I just need any kind jet
engine probably produces enough heat
without a spectacle to be on the verge
of bacon custom juggler okay we're
talking ye all the armor here um
how he oldie I'll medieval yeah in 15th
century yeah I'll give you that it can
be traced back to at least the 14th
century survived until about the 18th is
it in mice country yes very much
I'm gonna say what on the walkie aparts
the of this fine nation of are I've yes
I were talking salad southern the kind
of place where they throw cheese
downhill and chase it when tibialis you
can go to any old shop and find still
cheese it's not quite that vile the
thrill of the hunt old man Oh
Russia who wants a knee down that
doesn't fight back I mean there's
someone out there bless you in
Gloucestershire what is Gloucester it
isn't glass of the cheese roll cheese
roll it someone out there has their
uncle and goes in the hospital and years
later how did you how did you break your
uncle about it well I was chasing a
giant Eden however it is the
Gloucestershire cheese-rolling for
anyone doesn't know is he event every
spring in Gloucestershire where they get
a lot of people to talk the hill chuck a
roll of cheese down and then I will just
kind of rag dolls after it they say you
meant to run down the hill after belt
and it's a less of a race for a windmill
come flailing yeah yeah whoo-hoo gotcha
gee who wants a placid tasteless cheese
when you can have one that's run wild
and free and develop true tastes the
fella do you just got a lot it to a
supermarket get get a mullah crunch
corner and Wang it down a hill yes
better it's hanging chill only
I'm by the way the cheese rolling things
the last few years can you tell me why
why it's not quite but as safe as it
might have been that landmines
yeah it's rolling landmines down does a
bit you know due to cheese shortages
lotion was it still in the cow the
answer is that it was official until
about 2010 then it got banned on grounds
of health and safety so people just turn
up and do it anyway baby without as much
medical support Oh Glen's good on your
Gloucester shins
a long time ago you asked whether it was
down south yeah and uh well sweet bottom
left bottom right those references to it
in Essex but there's also references to
it in Staffordshire up near
burton-on-trent so it's all inner self
its itself Thank You York Sherman okay
yeah and as us in this house whether
drink be wrong and the teat is funny is
it that certain local yeoman of certain
standing must donate X much to the local
Lord from the first cut of bacon of the
year or that's what I was going to go no
it's actually it's bacon that is given
to someone and dreams there's only one
person at this table who would be
eligible for it right now married man
married man his partner yes hello
no points no he did say he did so you
got to be virtuous as well mate hey hey
now it's given a year and a day after
the wedding cool to a man and his wife
alright as this is you know ancient
times it was it was a man and his wife
indeed yes yet it who can attest to
something after a year and a day that
they've not done it haha
they've done it every day yes that's
grounds for annulment
nah ah naughty you're right a bit you're
closer with our children did something
to do with the marriage it's not I'm not
doing anything else it's something they
feel about the marriage divorce no
widely opposite even at your marriage
upgraded to a super marriage look I
think oh you kind of already is at this
point you would do it again you would
recommend it to a friend I'm gonna get
ready of hours I'm gonna give Gary the
point that you don't regret it that you
have never regretted it in that year and
a defo if you can testify that you know
i'm not going to ask you that question
guy i believe you can test whether
you've never this way i'm do me some
bacon
hahaha and the other thing is it's gonna
get to like day 360 photos yeah it's
been pretty poor but we want this bacon
oh yeah there's a bit of a Kanaan the
way so how about i think i think we can
one the second year on the back of the
bacon yeah
flush your bacon is actually referred to
in a very famous book Chaucer yeah
absolutely right before Edwin Chaucer in
a way that makes clear the referee
we'll already be known to the reader
okay widespread did he do it look down
the camera and go you know what I mean
hello um it's in the wife of arts
problem is that the well behind me right
yes I did look down the camera go if you
know what I mean yeah the bacon was not
fat for them I threw that some men hand
in Essex at Don mu which is the place
that I'm mispronouncing that obviously
because sure that's good effort I'd like
you probably actually waited I'd like to
point out that I know nothing about
Chaucer I just know that's an old
whenever I say Chaucer I get it right
yeah and then then he gave them to him
and they pronounced a ding a ding nose
evening from table who do and biscuits
of mystery food we gather right which
witch trials as they were called one day
seven o'clock news I'm flitch trials
that light is that like a witch trial I
accused you of being bacon I'm gonna
have to burn you well this thing is he's
puttin a penguin rubble battle for their
spit thank you my dick in the ocean is
eternal go round impressions Pig or
goose ah train ah goose on a train ha ha
that's got an old for some reason I love
the way the goosey said we just sat on
the train it always ends up on the train
but you said up here what's there
there's a lovely old thing in
linguistics um about mass and count
nouns or difference between them listen
there was a goose on the train versus
there was goose on the right the worst
thing is just talking about the copilot
from um what are you required to bring
along to a to a flitch trial to prove
that applesauce FFI Oh better question
of who are you required to produce vicar
not quite your mum is the best man I'll
do something like that you I say
witnesses of some species yeah neighbors
oh yes all of your neighbors to prove ya
straight through them only rouse yeah I
probably work a lot and well in a lot of
these kind of cases we're working as I
do with these kind of things to do with
oh yeah an archivist out here yeah a lot
of these kind of in kind of
non-consummation cases are all straight
a lot of the evidence comes from
neighbors who have obviously people at
the back window gone and that's not the
message you know so assuming you win the
footer of bacon yeah what what happens
you get there you get the bacon and then
feast for friends and family a grand
ceremony with trumpets tablets and all
other manner of min story yes that's
where you expected imagine for that kind
of Sighs a thing mm-hmm
I know you been doing that a lot I was
gonna say there's a lot of weddings
we're talking about it and what we just
got if we just got pigs and pigs and
pigs and minstrels MCed from play this
is the thing it doesn't seem to have
been claimed all that often always
really sings that song in the books but
you've got a thread yeah
how many times is the famous split chat
done mode known to have been claimed I'm
gonna say really low life long live or
something like that I'm gonna split the
difference and say 9 I'm gonna give Gary
2.6 really so that we know about
when was it repealed um it sort of fell
fell apart in this 15 16th century
dissolution of monasteries around them
okay um but it was revived in Victorian
times of course not
in the in their quest for editing year
all the diligence yeah yeah yeah can you
still do it now I'm gonna say boom I
don't know that maybe he paid for the
bacon or something like that I can see I
could just go to the butchers and pay
for Baker no no yeah you could have this
area money but you must good and just
bacon you can't um no you can actually
go every four years once every four
years every leap year in DUMBO there is
the dumb mo flick trials committee
completed complete with jury
yeah next one's in 2016 oh if a was me I
would be trying a platter one leg a
blanket but I've now looked up the ocean
now do it the next one will be on the
9th of July 2016 because there is a
website of course for the Dumbo flitch
trial search yeah um there is a list of
the successful claimant going all the
way back to 1445 good work
and they've also awarded Fletch's to a
couple of couples who might that be
and Diana point in fact I'll adopt a
flitch art Prince Andrew and Sarah folks
and just got a copy of the flitch oath
what what's the flick shows I pledge
allegiance to this bacon of what you
have given me tar in 12 months time a
day repented not in thought in any way
which is actually a fairly strong oath
to Terra Anna you've never ever wondered
any point during that don't forget the
medieval fear of hell in church and damn
near and everything else that's actually
a serious I would tear up so you can
still do it if any one of us got married
at some point in 2015 and that is about
all there is to it so it does continue
they have patrons who are providing the
bacon and making sure at companies it is
one of these ridiculous Asian page
raising little butchers ridiculous
British traditions that continues on to
this day good at the end the show
congratulations Gary yes you win a gift
certificate for the shop owned by a
treasure hunt skyrunner which sells
small rodents pests that live in hair
and adult magazines
it's my slice advice by Chanukah rice so
enjoy that certificate so I'm to run out
of these job to do suggest some more
always good it just built melt melt
melody no no respect in the meantime
thank you to Chris Cole to Gary Brannen
democra he I've been Tom Scott we'll see
you next time today's show is sponsored
by the new STI boardgame hungry hungry
her Peas say it's the tune that blur did
that landed on the moon on Mars with
eagle - why didn't like wait did London
London high velocity downward I know
there's a thin line between landing and
impact but that's a wife all the time
are the one thing I do know a war
happens we got battered chips oh I took
very different reaction talent Oh Matt
went yeah yeah you can see I'm with my
on this